this right over here is an exercise
about the Spanish-American war and AP
American history on Khan Academy
and we start off in student mode and
notice if the student asks for an
explanation it doesn't just give the
answer it does what a good tutor would
do and just try to nudge the student in
the right direction and also notice that
everything is monitored the teacher can
see what the student is interacting with
as a safety measure
now if we turn student mode off and we
go into teacher mode we see it's very
different when the teacher asks for an
explanation it's like having the
teacher's guide it will give as you can
see a very detailed explanation
and if the teacher wants a lesson plan
for it well they just need to ask for it
and they will get a very detailed lesson
plan with objectives and activities and
things to do for homework
and then if the teacher says all right
that's great conmigo you said give a
handout or give a reflection for
homework actually give the reflection
assignment and once again it will
construct that for the teacher and if a
teacher likes they can ask to customize
these lesson plans or these prompts or
these Reflections as much as they like
to make it more relevant to what their
students are doing this is something
that teachers oftentimes spend hours a
day working on and we hope to save them
a lot of time and a lot of energy for
their own well-being and for their
students